y en directo América llegó el momento de
hablar de salud por ello le doy la
bienvenida en el estudio a mi compañera
mar Romero salamar muy buenos días
Buenos días Andrés mar hoy vamos a
hablar de los riesgos futuros a los que
nos podemos enfrentar cuéntenos sí
estamos hablando sobre todo de las
pandemias no de riesgos como los que
pasamos con el covid 19 y lo hacemos
porque empezó la asamblea general de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud y este
ha sido uno de los principales llamados
que podemos hacer para prevenirlos cómo
nos podemos preparar Para futuras crisis
como la del covid 19 y para eso nos
acompaña Carlos Eduardo Pérez para
comentarlo médico infectólogo de la
Universidad Nacional de Colombia Muchas
gracias doctor por acompañarlos estamos
hablando como decíamos de estos posibles
riesgos de futuros pandemias pero mi
primera pregunta es de dónde puede
llegar este peligro qué debemos de estar
monitoreando Dónde debemos poner nuestra
atención
lo que hemos visto es que los virus que
están circulando sobre todo estos virus
respiratorios que están en el reino
animal y en el reino humano en el mismo
tiempo como el virus de la influenza
como los coronavirus y cualquier
cantidad de virus hay son muchas
familias las que hay son las que se
monitorizan y donde probablemente pueden
emerger esta y otras pandemias también
Es importante saber que los virus que
actualmente están circulando pueden
modificar su comportamiento hacer
variaciones y pueden llevar a estas
nuevas pandemias crisis epidémicas es
importante también monitorizar los virus
tanto en el reino animal como lo que
pasa en los humanos la reasociación de
estos virus pueden generar también
nuevas variantes que pueden afectarnos a
nosotros vivimos en una constante cerco
de enfermedades de este tipo y tenemos
que estar pendientes Porque seguramente
Tendremos que vivir otras pandemias en
el futuro doctor Pérez muy buenos días
lo saludo Andrés Meza Qué papel por
ejemplo el cambio climático en el
aumento de riesgos de nuevas pandemias
Andrés es definitivo hemos visto como el
comportamiento de los vectores Ah se ha
modificado con el cambio climático Qué
es eso los vectores son esos mosquitos
por ejemplo que transmiten virus un solo
mosquito es capaz de tener tres o cuatro
posibilidades de virus que pueda
transmitir y cada vez su adaptación es a
mayor altura y mayor grupos humanos
pueden ser afectados Además de eso la
acumulación de agua la pérdida de aguas
hace que se acumulen en ciertos sitios
estos vectores y se modifique el
comportamiento de las enfermedades
transmitidas por estas por estos agentes
luego sin duda el cambio climático hace
que sea más cercano la la probabilidad
de una nueva pandemia Y esa comunicación
que tenemos y la deforestación lo que se
está haciendo agrediendo el sistema el
medio ambiente pues inexorablemente va a
llevar que cosas que no conocemos hagan
parte de nuestro entorno tengan ese
desarrollo hacia una nueva enfermedad
devastadora Como la que pasamos no y de
hecho ya ya lo hemos visto como ha
sucedido el 19 de hecho es una
enfermedad zoonótica que nace desde los
animales la viruela del mono también así
que no es descabellado pensar que aquí
puede ser donde nacen los próximos
riesgos Pero pasamos a hablar de las
vacunas contra el 19 las vacunas
tuvieron el gran éxito de desarrollarse
muy rápidamente pero también el fracaso
digamos de una distribución no
igualitaria esto se podría replicar en
el futuro y cómo sobre todo se puede
mejorar la infraestructura para evitar
que esto vuelva a suceder
sí sin duda las vacunas fueron el delito
que marcó y paró esta pandemia eh
También el desarrollo de antivirales
farmacéuticos que también fue un gran un
gran logro sin embargo queda un gran
problema que los organismos
multilaterales no fueron eficientes no
se priorizó la vacunación al que más la
necesitaba sino que la podía comprar Y
definitivamente vimos como había una
inequidad en el acceso a las vacunas
pero a pesar de ser accesibles y
disponibles en varios sitios del mundo
la gente tampoco se vacunó completamente
y les puedo decir por mi práctica
profesional que hoy tengo pacientes que
pasé esta mañana a revisar con un Coby
19 en una unidad contensivo porque no se
han vacunado luego también es solamente
la disponibilidad de una maravilla como
la vacuna la accesibilidad pero también
la aceptación hacia la vacunación
nosotros exigimos una vacuna Pero cuando
lo tenemos disponible solamente se
vacunó el sesenta por ciento de la
población y no se ha reforzado sin
solamente el veinticinco por ciento de
la población luego el problema no
solamente la disponibilidad del
biológico sino también esos cambios en
el comportamiento creo martes sí es un
gran desafío la vacunología es el gran
Avance en la ciencia Pero tenemos muchos
otros factores que necesitamos alinear
accesibilidad conocimiento educación y
apropiación como parte de una estrategia
de vacunación que realmente sea actitud
doctor la pandemia nos tomó por sorpresa
a todos Creo que estas últimas
generaciones no habíamos visto una
situación de tal magnitud ahora la gran
pregunta es hay alguna forma de que
podamos predecir la próxima pandemia
es como los volcanes sabemos dónde están
es una amenaza constante pero las
pandemias como todo sean impredecibles
se van juntando factores y esos factores
son los que pueden desarrollar en dónde
está produciéndose nuevas resurrección
de virus dónde están circulando nuevos
agentes infecciosos Cómo se está
perdiendo la inmunidad para algunos de
ellos no lo sabemos son esos científicos
realmente destacados que están en el
campo monitorizando los que nos pueden
alertar pero está en nosotros el respeto
al medio ambiente conservar una vida
sana y saludable mantener
la etiqueta en el comportamiento que
tenemos que tener cuando estemos
enfermos saber aceptar la medicina
preventiva a aprender de que vacunarse
no hace daño son muchos procesos para
que eso no pase pero es impredecible una
una pandemia pero seguramente va a
suceder y mucho más pronto lo que
podamos creer Carlos doctor Una última
pregunta rápidamente el cómic 19 la
experiencia que hemos pasado nos ha
ayudado a prepararnos hacia el futuro o
al contrario nos ha debilitado y ha
mostrado digamos nuestras flaquezas
yo creo que ha tenido esa paradoja nos
ha fortalecido por ejemplo en la ciencia
en la comunicación
en en podernos juntar para poder
resolver un problema solo se pudo ser
capaz la unión científica y la unión
hace la ciencia con desafío hay otros
desafíos por ejemplo la comunicación
vimos que fue un gran Elemento de los
medios de comunicación para superar la
pandemia pero la infodemia con gran
enemigo Y tenemos debilidades por
ejemplo los organismos multilaterales la
falta de accesibilidad los recursos
económicos las economías frágiles y la
fragilidad humana creo que pasarán
décadas para entender qué fue lo que
vivimos lo que tenemos que hacer es
vivir el presente seguir estudiando
confiar en la ciencia ser mejores para
todos y cuidarnos entre todos para tener
un mundo mejor Mira estaba el Doctor
Carlos Eduardo Pérez asesor científico
de Franz 24 Muchas gracias por este
análisis sobre cómo ha sido Cómo ha sido
este balance de la pandemia Kobe 19 y
también como debemos prepararnos para
futuras pandemias mar Así es Andrés
Muchísimas gracias muchas gracias
también y nos vemos entonces mañana con
una nueva sección de salud hasta mañana